okay so I've had a lot of requests for a
video on the North Germanic languages so
today I present to you a video on
Swedish Norwegian Danish
and Finnish what hello everyone welcome
to the line focus Channel and my name is
Paul today I'm going to talk about the
North Germanic languages of the Nordic
nations that includes the Scandinavian
languages Swedish Danish and Norwegian
and I will also touch on the languages
of Icelandic and Faroese I wanted to
call this video the Scandinavian
languages because I just love the way
that word sounds Scandinavian but to the
people of that region the word
Scandinavian only refers to Denmark
Sweden and Norway and not to the other
countries that I want to talk about so
if I say the Nordic nations that also
includes Iceland the Faroe Islands as
well as Finland I want to talk about the
North Germanic languages spoken in all
of those countries
so I decided on the title the North
Germanic languages of the Nordic nations
and please note that Finnish is not a
North Germanic language it belongs to a
separate language family entirely
there are about 20 million native
speakers of North Germanic languages and
that includes about 9 million speakers
of Swedish mainly in Sweden but also as
a minority language in Finland 6 million
speakers of Danish mainly in Denmark but
also as a minority language in the
southern Asian region of northern
Germany and in Greenland 5 million
speakers of Norwegian mainly in Norway
320,000 speakers of Icelandic mainly in
Iceland 90,000 speakers of Faroese about
2/3 of them living in the Faroe Islands
and the rest mainly in Denmark the North
Germanic languages are as you probably
guessed a branch of the Germanic
language family all Germanic languages
developed from proto-germanic which was
spoken around 500 BCE proto-germanic
possibly originated in Scandinavia and
different varieties of Germanic began to
emerge with migration runic inscriptions
from the 2nd century CE II show us that
by that time proto-germanic had began to
separate into distinct Western eastern
and northern dialects the northern
dialect was spoken in Scandinavia and is
today often referred to as proto Norse
and became the ancestor of all the North
Germanic languages proto Norse was
spoken from around the 2nd century ce e
to the 8th century CE and by the
beginning of the Viking era in the 8th
century CE II it had evolved into
dialects that are collectively referred
to as Old Norse during the next few
hundred years Vikings seafaring Norse
people explored much of Europe by sea
and river conquering lands and
establishing settlements and bringing
their language with them during this
time Old Norse was divided into three
mutually intelligible dialects of Old
East North Old West Norse and old
gutnish all the east north was spoken in
Sweden and Denmark as well as their
overseas settlements in Russia England
and in Danish settlements in Normandy
Old West Norse was spoken in Norway as
well as its overseas settlements the two
most notable were Iceland and the Faroe
Islands but also Ireland Scotland and
the Isle of Man and Norwegian
settlements in Normandy old goodness was
mainly spoken on the island of Gotland
which is today part of Sweden as well as
some overseas settlements to the east
these west east and goodness varieties
of Old Norse gradually developed into
the modern North Germanic languages
around the 14th century see II
Western branch of languages consists of
Norwegian Icelandic and Faroese as well
as some other extinct languages the
Eastern branch consists of Swedish and
Danish the goodness branch consists of
only the goodness language which is
still spoken to some extent on the
island of Gotland but these days the
North Germanic languages are generally
not thought of in terms of east-west and
goodness they are thought of in terms of
continental and insular the Continental
languages are Danish Swedish and
Norwegian and the insular languages are
Icelandic and Faroese these categories
are based on the mutual intelligibility
of the languages rather than on the
genetic root language that they come
from Norwegian is grouped with Swedish
and Danish because even though Icelandic
and Norwegian developed from the same
Old West Norse Norwegian is today much
more intelligible with Swedish and
Danish one reason for that is the
political union of Denmark and Norway
from 1536 to 1814 during this time the
written Norwegian language stopped being
used and it was replaced by the written
Danish language and this had a big
impact on the spoken dialects of
Norwegian especially the central and
eastern dialects the continental
languages also underwent a lot of
influence from middle Low German which
is an influence that didn't affect
Icelandic and Faroese the three
continental languages can be referred to
as the Scandinavian languages when
talking about the Scandinavian languages
it's important to note that there is a
significant amount of dialectal
variation within each language in fact
the three languages are made up of a
dialect continuum that means if you
travel in one direction the dialects
gradually change the further you go that
means for example that if you are on
Norwegian living near the border with
Sweden you probably have an easier time
understanding your neighbor just across
the border in Sweden than you do a
Norwegian from the other side of the
country even though you are supposedly
speaking a different language from that
Swedish person this makes it kind of
hard to determine at what point these
dialects become different languages or
if they are in fact different languages
at all the three languages are all more
or less intelligible depending on where
the dialect lies on that continuum and
the written languages are almost
entirely intelligible Danish seems to be
the odd man out with its complex
phonology that has come to be quite
distinct from the written language
Swedes and Norwegians often say that
Danish people
sound like they're speaking with a
potato in their mouth I can't actually
confirm if they do speak with the potato
in their mouth so Scandinavians can you
let me know if that's true and the
comments down below I have Danish roots
so I'm allowed to make fun of Danes from
what I understand Norwegians have the
easiest time understanding the other two
Scandinavian languages though they
understand Swedish better than Danish
Swedes can generally understand or
Weejun but they have much more trouble
understanding Danish because of its
pronunciation and Danes can more or less
understand Norwegian and to a lesser
extent they can understand some Swedish
from what I understand Scandinavians
will generally not speak the other
person's language they will speak their
own language while making an effort to
understand the other person's speech and
maybe they will slow down and clarify
things when necessary but when they have
significant trouble communicating they
might switch to English which isn't that
tough for them because Scandinavians are
magical geniuses when it comes to
learning English in this kind of
situation where you have three closely
related languages that kind of blend
together on a continuum the languages
are not defined by the spoken variety
but rather by the official standard
language associated with that country or
region in Denmark there a standard
Danish in Sweden there a standard
Swedish and in Norway there is standard
Norwegian or wait no there are actually
two standard Norwegians that's right
Norway actually has two official
standard written languages welcome all
mean lush bokmal which means book
language is a Danish influenced standard
language which is very close to standard
Danish but which uses Norwegian
pronounciation Nino chic or new
Norwegian is intended to be a pure
version of Norwegian based on Norway's
more conservative western dialects which
standard language Norwegians are
educated in depends on the region they
grow up in but despite having two
official standard languages Norwegians
don't really speak them
Norwegians generally speak their own
local dialect whenever they are speaking
even in formal situations and even when
they're speaking to people from the
other Scandinavian countries because of
this Norwegians have to get used to
understanding a wide variety of spoken
dialects and that's probably part of
what makes it easier for them to
understand Swedish and Danish but that
of course is just my speculation so
native speakers you can confirm or
disconfirm that so let's take a look at
the three continental languages and see
just how similar they are in English I
love you first in Swedish yog and got a
bang now in Norwegian yeah it'll still
die now in Danish yay else good eye as
you can see these sentences are very
similar but with some differences in
spelling and pronunciation in particular
the Swedish pronunciation is a little
different from the other two listen to
the first person singular pronoun again
yaagh
yay yay at the end of the Swedish one
you could hear a hard G sound it's not
always pronounced that way it depends on
exactly where the speaker is from
another example dogs are the best pets
first in Swedish boom da da de beste
hear them next in Norwegian who know are
the best - elidio and in Danish
who knew Eddie best EK lead you here we
see some more noticeable differences
even though the sentences are still
really similar notice the difference in
the word for dogs boom bada who know who
knew the Swedish word is pretty much
pronounced as written but in the
Norwegian and Danish word some letters
are not pronounced and notice the
different words for pets who um Sheila
do Kayla do the Swedish word is
different from the other two and the
Norwegian and Danish words are almost
the same but with a different initial
sound and slightly different vowels
another example tomorrow I will go to
Germany in Swedish in Morgan's car York
tilt is glam and in Norwegian amorn
Scully I tilt Islam and in Danish Iman
Scalia is us Glenn in this case the
Norwegian and Danish sentences are
basically the same but the Swedish
sentence is pronounced a little
differently again we hear those hard G
sounds which aren't present in the
Norwegian and Danish sentences but again
they're not always pronounced in Swedish
either one more example in English the
party was fun because I liked the music
first in Swedish Captain mercury-free
are generally shaken then in Norwegian
fest Margay for the I lik to Michigan
and in Danish Festa show Fadi the iku
Neely who Seaton in these sentences the
preferred word for fun is different in
each language Kay
gay show the word meaning because is
also different in Swedish and in
Norwegian and Danish it's spelled the
same but pronounced differently sir
Jordy what key and like is expressed
differently in all three languages yada
or Gilad ah with the hard G sound more
like the voice in the recording litter
Kuh nearly in Danish it's expressed in
two words the first one meaning could
the phrase literally means could suffer
and listen to the difference for the
word for music in Norwegian and Danish
listen to how the K sound disappears in
Danish Michigan who Seaton and listen to
the pronunciation of this phrase again
show the end of the second word seems to
vanish this could be part of that potato
phenomenon discussed earlier so you can
probably see just how similar these
three languages are and you can probably
see how relatively speaking they are
easy for English speakers to learn they
are all category one languages according
to the American foreign service
institute which trains diplomats for
their overseas assignments none of the
North Germanic languages are amongst the
most widely spoken languages in the
world and people from the Nordic
countries generally speak excellent
English so is it a waste of time to
learn a North Germanic language of
course not if you're interested in the
cultures and the history of that region
then learning one of the languages could
bring you immense joy and because the
three Scandinavian languages are so
similar learning one of them can unlock
the doors to the other ones especially
of the written languages and if you're
an avid traveler or you want to go
backpacking around the world that you
will probably meet a surprising number
of Scandinavians and knowing their
language or even one of the other two
languages will help you break the ice
and get to know some wonderful and
possibly highly attractive people and if
you are interested in the old Nordic
cultures then you might benefit from
learning Icelandic since written
Icelandic is still very similar to Old
Norse so don't hesitate to start
learning one of the North Germanic
languages which could be your portal
into a whole new world so the question
of the day native speakers of North
Germanic languages what is your
experience communicating with the
speakers of other languages which of the
other languages do you understand the
most and how do you bridge that
communication gap we'd like to know and
everyone else jump in and leave whatever
comments you want thank you for watching
and
have a nice day
[Music]